[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i'm going to be doing
something a little bit different i'm
going to be sharing with you some behind
the scenes secrets from the sets of the
harry potter films these secrets span
the series and give us just a quizzical
glimpse into the workings of a truly
magical production they also range from
light-hearted and fun to a little bit
more serious anyway these secrets and
factoids speak for themselves so i won't
dawdle any longer let's get started
one the ford anglia's you might remember
the flying ford anglia the light blue
forward that was enchanted by arthur
weasley and enabled it to fly the ford
anglia notably makes an appearance in
the second film when harry and ron
hijack it in order to drive to hogwarts
after dobby seals the entrance to
platform nine and three-quarters just as
the boys are arriving at the school they
drive the anglia straight into the
whomping willow which certainly did some
damage what you might be surprised to
hear however is that an astonishing 14
ford anglias were destroyed in the
filming process
two professor snape wore contacts zebra
snape potions professor defence against
the dark arts professor lily lover and
one time hogwarts headmaster was played
by alan rickman rickman played the
perfect snape but what many don't know
is that rickman went to considerable
lengths to achieve at this level of
perfection in fact one little detail
about snape's character his eyes was
something which rickman paid
particularly close attention to wearing
black contacts throughout the films in
order to properly convey the darkness of
snape's character 3. harry and
hermione's appearance when the books
were adapted to film producers wanted to
try and replicate as much as they could
this meant ensuring that characters
resembled their descriptions from the
books however in the case of harry and
hermione this proved it difficult harry
played by daniel radcliffe was meant to
have green eyes but daniel had an
allergic reaction to his contact lenses
hermione played by emma watson was meant
to have buck teeth however she didn't
end up wearing them because they
affected her ability to speak
4. jk rowling almost played a role
though rowling is certainly not an
actress she was originally considered
for the role of harry's mother in the
philosopher's stone which could have
perhaps been a nice cameo however
rolling in the casting directors
eventually decided that it would be best
that they go with someone else though
it's not a particularly large role
actress geraldine somerville who
eventually went on to assume the role
did a good job 5. voldemort was played
by five different actors what many don't
know is that over the course of the
eight films created five different
actors portrayed voldemort ralph fiennes
is perhaps the most well-known portrayal
however there were four other actors
involved who depicted voldemort at
different stages of his life the
voldemort from the first film was played
by richard bremner who as we know was
stuck to the back of corel's head
christian coulson played the teenage tom
riddle from the chamber of secrets frank
delaine played the menacing young riddle
shown chatting with slughorn about
horcruxes in the half-blood prince and
ralph fein's nephew hero finds tiffin
played the eleven-year-old tom in the
orphanage
six honeydukes honeydukes a wizarding
sweet shop located in hogsmeade sold all
kinds of wizarding suites this meant
stocking the shelves the shop to the
brim however with the cast full of
children this can be dangerous which is
why the cast were told that the
honeyduke sweets were coated in lacquer
preventing the otherwise inevitable
disappearance of candy 7. hedwig hedwig
harry's trusty white owl and animal
companion was given to him right at the
beginning of his journey into the
wizarding world however what many don't
realize is that hedwig was actually
played by seven different male owls
gizmo casper oops swoops o-o elmo and
bandit 8. professor trollony as we know
professor trelawny hogwarts divination
professor was expertly played by
oscar-winning actress emma thompson
however what many don't know is that the
role almost went to tilda swinton who
eventually turned it down due to
scheduling conflicts
nine headlights during the filming of
the second movie harry potter and the
chamber of secrets nurses were brought
onto the set after a severe case of
headlights broke out among many of the
young actors
10. homework there are plenty of scenes
in the harry potter films where the
child actors have school work in front
of them as it turns out sometimes this
was their actual school work because
they're kids it gave the actors an
opportunity to get their schoolwork done
in between shooting 11. tom felton stole
too much food apparently during filming
tom felton stole so much food which he
put in his robe pockets and snacks so
often that his pockets had to eventually
be sewn shut 12. the bats in hagrid's
hut as it turns out the bats seen flying
around in hagrid's hut were actually
real bats which posed real challenges
when it came to training them radcliffe
once remarked that they urinated
everywhere 13. maggie smith maggie smith
who so expertly portrayed minerva
mcgonagall was in good health for most
of the films but at one point ended up
being diagnosed with cancer heroically
smith underwent cancer treatment while
filming the sixth movie 14. crush on
hermione both rupert grint and daniel
radcliffe had a crush on co-star emma
watson at one point or another while
filming the harry potter films 15.
alfonso quaron allegedly director
alfonzo quaron who directed prisoner of
azkaban had never actually read the
harry potter novels or seen the first
two movies when he was offered the job
of director guillermo del toro convinced
him to accept the offer telling him
don't be stupid read them immediately
16. crookshanks hermione's pet cat
crookshanks the half nasal was actually
played by two persian red cats cracker
jack and pumpkin apparently the trainers
would save the cat's shed fur roll it
into balls and clip them onto the cats
in order to achieve crook shanks's main
g appearance 17. luna's dirigible plum
earrings in the books luna wears
dirigible plum earrings and so naturally
ivana lynch was a hp superfan showed up
to her audition with a pair that she'd
made herself she ended up wearing the
same ones in the film 18 dementors
dementors the gigantic foul creatures
that represent unhappiness and despair
were actually created by rowling as a
way of personifying all the aspects of
depression which she herself battled
with 19. tom felton lied in his audition
tom felton true to his character of
draco actually lied during his harry
potter audition when he told the casting
directors that he had read the books
which of course he hadn't 20. weasley
clock the weasley clock was a magical
clock belonging to the weasleys that
individually monitored each of their
whereabouts as it turned out the hands
on the weasley clock were actually
scissors with photos of the respective
actors on their handles
21. gary oldman gary oldman who played
sirius black harry's godfather became
quite good friends with daniel radcliffe
behind the scenes in fact oldman bought
radcliffe a bass guitar as a gift which
is interesting because sirius buys harry
a firebolt in the films
22 the giant squid apparently the giant
squid that lives in the black lake of
hogwarts which we never got to see was
supposed to have an appearance in the
film franchise unfortunately however it
was cut from the final film
23. rupert grint plus spiders ron
weasley is a sufferer of arachnophobia
aka affair of spiders and this is clear
in the films however as it turns out
rupert grint who plays ron suffers from
the same fear
24 privet drive as it turns out the
scenes at number 4 privet drive the home
of the dursleys were originally shot on
an actual street with real houses
however later on models were built as
they no longer had access to the houses
previously used 25 the great hall when
we see the great halls the first time in
the films it's quite a spectacle however
one interesting thing about this set is
that the cast hadn't seen the great hall
prior to shooting the sorting hat scene
which meant that their amazement and all
upon first walking into it was
completely genuine and that's it for
this video there are certainly plenty
more behind the scenes factoids out
there but i'll save those for another
video would you all be interested in a
series where i separated these secrets
by film let me know in the comment
section below also if you don't follow
me on instagram already go check it out
at hp theory until next time it does not
do to dwell on dreams forget to live
[Music]